generally writers need to write what
hurts
that doesn't mean everything is tragic
but it means you are tapping into what
you must say
does every writer need to know how to
write a pilot
yes
every writer needs to write a pilot um
first of all it's the coin of the realm
that people who people meaning agents
producers
even people who are not in the
television business
uh
will read a pilot before before they
will read every anything else uh in a
pilot they get the originality of your
voice and your ability to tell the story
and how to write
in a shorter amount of time than having
to slog through 120 pages of a feature
film so they get all of the same
advantage
uh in a shorter reading time the other
thing is that a pilot
is likely to show a possible producer
or fellowship or
agent
that you
really understand in a compact way
how to deliver for today's audience
uh people watch television they are not
looking at movies so unless you are your
goal in life
uh is to uh write episode 900 of some
blockbuster action fantasy adventure
you really need to have a pilot for an
original show it doesn't mean that show
will be made it will not be made but
this is your showpiece this is your
masterwork
that will then get you the chance to be
on us
on the staff of a show
at which point you can then come back to
your pilot and maybe then it'll be made
but absolutely pilot writing
is
is the craft you need and i would tell
any beginning writer that they should
have more than one pilot
uh one pilot isn't enough for one thing
you learn
from every script you write and you just
get better and better
the other is that
um
you may find that after your first pilot
which you thought was the story you had
to tell that there's more to you than
that there are more stories to tell
generally shows that get bought
are built on underlying materials they
are
built on books
or or movies or other
other underlying
assets
so the chance of selling your pilot and
getting it made or slight
but it's the thing without which you
can't work
so not just one pilot but several pilots
and expect them never to be made this is
your sort of calling card this is your
almost resume
that's right
they might
i mean they might be made you can hope
they'll be made
you never want to say to yourself this
will never be made
but
they are evidence of craft
their evidence of voice
uh they are who you are
as a writer
and uh
and who you are should not be one thing
i mean you can do more than one and you
should for one thing they'll get better
what questions should a writer be asking
themselves
when they're about to embark on a pilot
the question
to not ask is how can i imitate
something that has already been
successful
that's what to not do
i know sometimes people say well let me
game the business i thought this works
i'll do
three percent of that and five of that
and you know here let me do all this and
yeah i got it and i'm going to get rich
and famous this doesn't work
um
what really works
is uh is the story that only you can
tell
and
you whoever you are
knows that generally writers need to
write what hurts
that doesn't mean everything is tragic
but it means you are tapping into what
you must say because you have such a
great need to say it now that can be
interpolated in a way that's not
personal you could do that through
history for example or even through an
imaginary character it doesn't have to
be you
but it needs to be something that you
need to convey
emotionally and psychologically
and if once you know what that is
you can see if there's a way to attach
that to something broader than just
being your purely personal intimate tale
and that can be as i say
political social
historical
it can be anything you'd like it to be
you can have music it can have visual
material uh it can have all sorts of
things but it really needs to come from
uh honesty
and it's
anybody who reads a lot of scripts can
tell right away if something is
dishonest
that is if something is just trying to
make a sale
and it's a turn off
what if somebody doesn't want to go
there and they say well i don't want if
you don't want to do that you shouldn't
be a writer
you know go do some other job there are
plenty of jobs where you don't have to
be introspective or honest
in the world and there are plenty of
jobs even in the industry
where you don't have to be introspective
or honest
uh but if you want to be a writer
there's a reason you want to write be
it's because there's something you want
to write about there's something you
want to say
and i think that's your obligation
uh to the universe as and to yourself
how much of the world needs to be
created in the pilot
all of the world and all of the
characters are from the writer
you need to know everything
nothing is for the director to figure
out later
now that doesn't mean you don't have
assets from the actors who will bring
depths and insight into the characters
that are beyond what you may have
imagined
the director
may also be able to present a scene in a
way that amplifies some elements that
you only sketched in
the costumes might add something
the location can add wonderful things so
it's a collaborative field
but
the writer is the first dreamer among
many dreams
and
there are
there's a basis in uh in knowing
what you are dealing with here and that
means creating the entire world by that
i don't mean specifics of the location
the scout will do that but you need to
understand all of the energies which are
in this situation that you're that
you're going for
and there is no difference between
character and world there are characters
that could only exist
in the situation where they are
and worlds that will be different
depending on the story look at all the
different medical shows that are not the
same medical show grey's anatomy does
not look like house and neither of them
looks like er
they're all medical shows
but they are different worlds because
the world comes from who the characters
are
beyond that uh world building as an
exercise
is really
not something i would
suggest that writers spend a lot of time
dealing with i have seen people make a
mistake of going off into fantasy worlds
and
you know
decorating characters with feathers and
doing things that can only be done with
animatronic tronics and maybe that'll
work on some feature films i think it's
a waste of time in television
sure i mean if we think back to the
original blade runner that world was so
unique right and even if you watch the
next blade runner it's still beautiful
worlds but there was something about
that original world
that just it was almost impossible to
recreate well if you look at game of
thrones
uh which has seven worlds
actually seven locations very very
different
uh filmed in different countries whether
you're in northern ireland or whether
you're in
some tropical place or a desert
there's absolutely
unique and important
locations
and different sets of characters in each
world who express the
sense of those worlds
they're all coalesced within a certain
time frame a certain time
in life a sort of medievalish time and a
certain way that people deal with each
other so that was
definitely
an extreme case of world building
but again
what made game of thrones the great
success it is well it's because we
really were caring about those
characters yeah they were great battle
scenes
uh and the worlds were gorgeous and the
costumes were gorgeous
from george or george rr martin who
wrote the underlying novels uh
the
imagining of the worlds were there from
the beginning so the writer had that
from minute one
and then it was just up to everybody
else to express that
but uh no writers have to
have to do it all
this is your world this is your
character this is your dream this is
your story so
nothing's off the hook of oh well the
actor will do that or the director will
do that that's not the case you will do
that